[Musique]
bonjour a tous voila j'ai un peu trop
d'énergie je me prénomme sébastien échos
qui je vous présente
ted qui est l'un de mes compagnons de
jeu ou plutôt l'une des machines que
l'on développe dans ma société
donc tout d'abord je vais faire un lien
entre la connaissance et ce métier
qu'est la robotique pour vous amener sur
des compréhensions de pourquoi ces choix
et quel est le lien entre la
connaissance est un doux rêve surtout
d'un jeune gamin qui était réservé
optimiste c'est qu'il est toujours
encore tout a commencé pour moi il y a
un peu plus de 20 ans il ya un peu plus
de vingt ans j'avais la chance j'avais
deux grands-pères passionnés amoureux de
la vie et de mes grands mères bien
évidemment et qui partager une passion
celle d'aider les autres qui aimait
venir en support des autres et quand moi
j'en avais 10 et eu à peu près 75
ils ont toujours trouvé le moyen de
m'émerveiller à utiliser des
connaissances et des compétences que
l'on peut voir sur pour l'un un métier
de garagiste et l'autre un métier
d'ébéniste et de pouvoir au final
utiliser leur leurs patients pardon pour
pouvoir aider l'homme et des autres
aider leur prochain étant petit fils
j'ai aussi pu voir quelque chose avec le
témoin du vieillissement de mes grands
pères le témoin de troubles
musculo-squelettiques le témoin de
doigts qui se déformés par l'arthrose
le témoin de maladies qui commencent à
arriver mais sur le tout le témoin d'une
énergie extraordinaire celle de sourire
celle de jamais se plaindre
celle de toujours avoir envie de
continuer qui fait que pour l'un à 87
ans il était présent pour l'un de mes
déménagements à passer la faux dans mon
jardin pour couper l'herbe et oui il
voulait pas utiliser attend d'eux
dommage et à 92 ans à 4 passes sous un
évier emprunt de m'aider à réparer une
fuite
ce point c'est important c'est que c'est
une base de ma première partie kim a
structuré et qui a amené mon ma
connaissance
deuxième étape faut je restitue un peu
mon époque je suis dans les années 80 90
80 90 c'est l'arrivée
déjà durant premier pc chez moi dans mon
ordinateur j'ai eu la chance d'avoir mon
père passionné de technologies qui a eu
dans les fin des années 80 le premier pc
son premier pc et du coup je suis aussi
dans un univers baigné entre goldorak
des films de science fiction terminator
mais aussi surtout johnny 5 jeux patient
n'est qu'ils connaissent et le petit
robot qui se trouve quelque part vers là
et ce petit robot a vécu une histoire
assez rigolote c'est qu'il y ait un
court circuit et ce court-circuit a
amené cette machine a commencé à vivre
comprendre interpréter et de
l'interprétation qui lui du monde à
aider l'homme et enfin pour combler
cette partie là je suis pas devin
personne n'est parfait mais en tout cas
chez postbank et je viens d'une ville
qui a le futuroscope qui a porté des
valeurs du futur de la technologie quand
vous êtes poidevin dans les années 90 au
déroulé du au début du futuroscope et
ben vous vivez dès dimanche après midi
dans un parc d'attraction avec des
écrans relativement fort relativement
avec de la technologie avec une vision
du monde et enfin pour terminer mes
études pour voir concevoir ces machines
il a fallu aussi poussé les études et
c'était surtout des rencontres des
rencontres de personnes des rencontres
en d'enseignants pour moi ça a été
surtout une révélation en cm2 cm2 un
enseignant james deviez qui va mener
deux passions une première les
l'équitation qui correspond au logo de
la société aujourd'hui le cheval qui est
aussi accessoirement le premier cobot de
l'homme et la deuxième passion les
échecs les échecs c'est quand même un
sujet hyper intéressant et passionnant
parce que c'est en jeu vous avez pour
obligation d'apprendre à savoir perdre
quand je dis apprendre à savoir perdre
c'est qu'à chaque fois vous perdez vous
enrichissez vous comprenez vous
améliorez votre algorithmes vous
améliorez votre connaissance
vous améliorez votre capacité à
comprendre combien de coureurs que
j'aide avance par rapport à l'autre en
face pour voir gagner
l'histoire faisant je suis devenu
ingénieur en automatique
et lors de ma dernière année j'ai fait
mon premier jeu d'échecs avec un
camarade de classe avec une intelligence
artificielle ou plutôt un algorithme
intelligence artificielle c'est quand
même des équations des algorithmes y
égaler x + b et quand même l'une des
bases ou des systèmes goulien sont comme
les bases de ces techno et du coup ce
jeu d'échecs a eu pour difficulté ou
plutôt moi je lui pour difficulté de
devoir le battre vous avez sûrement me
dire pourquoi est ce que je vous raconte
ma vie pourquoi je vous parle de mes
grands pères pourquoi est-ce que je vous
parle de goldorak
pourquoi est-ce que je vous parle
typiquement de mes enseignants
tout simplement parce que ça ça m'a créé
sacré ma connaissance il ya plein de
choses que j'ai pas garder mais ça
s'appelle de l'information mais en tout
cas tout ça ça m'a animé au final c'est
ses émotions que j'ai vécues de voir la
souffrance de ceux de mes grands pères
c'est les odeurs dans les ateliers
l'odeur de l'essence dans l'atelier de
mon grand-père ou l'odeur du bois dans
l'autre le goût des confitures de mes
grands mères mais aussi le sentiment
d'avoir des personnes qui me pousse qui
m'aident qui ont confiance en moi et qui
ont envie d'avancer
mine de rien tout ça c'était mon premier
socle ma première base et cette
connaissance est transformé en savoir
pour moi qui m'a défini qui m'a créé ma
propre culture
je vais pas parler pendant des heures de
mon parcours et de qui je suis je vais
surtout maintenant s'intéresser à la
connaissance et la connaissance
il est important pour moi de parler de
connaissances en parlant d'une grande
dame une personne que je n'ai
malheureusement pas eu l'occasion de
connaître mais qui a fait que j'ai
choisi la localisation de la société sur
nantes parce que c'est une p bien en
entreprise basée dans une rue qui se
nomme rue rose jenkins
ça va pas parler parler forcément à
beaucoup de monde mais la dame rose hill
queens et de finale la première femme
africaine à rentrer à l'école
polytechnique de paris mais aussi l'une
fin la deuxième femme en france à voir
la gouvernance d'un département de
recherche au sein de l'inria et cette
dame avait une passion la connaissance
la connaissance ou plutôt les systèmes
d'acquisition de la connaissance et
comment est ce que je vais transférer la
connaissance vers un autre système alors
je vous rassure tout de suite on va pas
rentrer dans le détail de ces travaux on
va pas rentrer dans le détail des
algorithmes on va juste faire un petit
résumé
pour pouvoir recentrer et comprendre
quel est le rôle d'un mathématicien ou
d'un développeur pardon informatique qui
va avoir pour objectif de dérouler un
programme d'intelligence un développeur
informatique va récolter de
l'information
ce qu'ont rappelé de la datar quand y en
a beaucoup ça s'appelle bien sûr de la
big data cette big data va être analysée
va être traitée mais surtout un moment
donné ce qu'il va y avoir d'importants
sait d'où vient cette date à est ce
qu'elle est bonne et ce qu'elle est
mauvaise du coup vous allez voir
l'apparition enfants même pas
l'apparition ça existe depuis la nuit
des temps de la blog shane la blog shane
pour faire simple c'est comme avec les
pigeons vous mettez une bague aux
pigeons ou l'envoyer d'un point a à un
point b
la personne reçoit le pigeon c'est que
l'information est pertinente qu'elle
vient bien de telles personnes sauf si
le pigeon a été piraté une fois que ce
pigeon est arrivé ou plutôt que cette
information est arrivé un processus va
le travail et en connaissances cette
connaissance va s'assimiler dans le
système va passer un deuxième tamis un
deuxième filtre qui va la structure et
en savoir vous savez c'est comme vos
cours d'histoire dans les cours
d'histoire qu'on a eu à l'époque on nous
a souvent parlé de 15 115 on a oublié
pourtant nous l'a dit à l'école que 15
115 c'est une guerre à marignan entre
des français et des italiens et que les
suisses sont venus aider et bref
françois 1er etc mais tout ça au final
vous l'avez mis de côté vous avez mis de
l'information de côté pour en conserver
une connaissance 15 115 qui au final n'a
aucun mot aucune utilité dans votre
quotidien
par contre le feu vous brûlez ça va vous
amener à votre capteur la peau la
sensation de aya sacré de la
connaissance
et oui le feu ça brûle et posé sa main
sur le feu ça fait mal et du coup de ça
vous à l'encré des réflexes qui va
construire votre savoir votre culture
votre croyance par rapport à le feu
brûle donc je vais éviter de le toucher
et je continue au final c'est ça le sens
aujourd'hui des informaticiens s'est
développé ces algorithmes et cet ami qui
vont filtrer l'information la
transformer en connaissance de
connaissances à savoir et de savoir à
comportement
comportement culture ces cultures vont
créer des croyances et oui les systèmes
peuvent avoir des croyances le feu brûle
donc je crois que le feu brûle et de
l'a71 connaissances accumulées reste du
coup en culture va devoir se transférer
ou pas mais le but du jeu c'est quand
même de transférer ce qu'on a et qui a
une prochaine un système et c'est un
petit peu les travaux de madame rosine
keynes qui était justement de s'assurer
du transfert de l'information de
s'assurer que dans notre cas ted
si présent plateformes mobiles
transférera ses prochains ces prochaines
versions l'information de ce qu'il a
acquis aujourd'hui c'est important tout
ce que je viens de dire parce qu'au
final c'est l'adn du système
on est en train aujourd'hui les
développeurs informatiques modèle une
adn modèle un adn un algorithme qui va
permettre d'avoir des comportements et
d'évoluer par contre attention ce que
j'ai à dire c'est que c'est le
développeur informatique qui est
responsable aussi du tamis
si par hasard il avait dit un jeu
d'échecs la reine avance que d'une casse
donc dans le jeu d'échecs la reine à la
tous les pouvoirs à peut faire ce
qu'elle veut mais s'il avait dit la
reine a le droit de s'avancer que d'une
case bas garry kasparov alors j'avais
perdu face à diplo et ça c'est important
c'est à dire c'est le développeur
informatique qui est concerné par cette
information
une fois qu'on a dit ça ce qui est
important c'est de comprendre que le
développeur informatique
un mathématicien chevronnés quelqu'un
qui a une culture mathématique assez
forte
au final son algorithme va dépendre de
lui va dépendre de sa vision sa vision
du monde
sa compréhension de la sémantique sa
compréhension des choses du bien et du
mal qui va re traduire dans le système
et cette compréhension peut avoir des
mauvaises interprétations
comment il entendait coopérer collaborer
effectivement ces deux termes qui au
final sont complètement différent dans
notre langue latine qui dans un anglais
proches sont à peu près similaires
collaboration
on va rester dans le même univers mais
cette sémantique est importante parce
que si je dis à mon système qu'il faut
collaborer et pas coopérer
qu'est ce que ça veut dire je vous faire
une telle cour de sémantique rapide mais
c'est tout mon sens par rapport au new
skies ou plutôt aux produits que l'on
développe chez dans ma structure la
coopération ça vient du latin copé rohr
ça veut dire qu'on opèrent conjointement
à chennevières conjoint conjointement
dans le latin ça veut dire couple donc
c'est à dire que quand je coopère c'est
comme un couple
c'est un projet de vie on a pour
objectif de travailler ensemble de
s'entraider de d'être vraiment unis pour
un objectif de vie commun commune à la
différence de collaborer collaboré ces
collaborent c'est plutôt deux collègues
de travail qui sont dans un mode plus
collaboration et qui ont un objectif pas
forcément de s'apprécier d'atteindre
l'objectif de la société est cet
objectif est important parce qu'au final
ils pourront être les meilleurs ennemis
du monde mais ils travailleront ensemble
je pense que vous les connaissez tous
vous les avez tous eu à un moment donné
autour de vous et bien évidemment
l'inversé faisable un collègue peut
devenir un bon coopérateurs quelqu'un
qui va avoir de l'entraidé s'enterrer
scène c'est très important parce qu'au
final si je met aujourd'hui une machine
américaine aux états unis avec la
terminologie collaborer que je programme
le système collabora et les personnes
dans un environnement plus anglo-saxon
comprendront ce que veut dire
collaboration alors que nous on
cherchera toujours à voir l'entr'aide
dans des pays anglo saxons ça c'est
rigolo cette histoire parce que quand on
a commencé à travailler sur nos machines
à faire des systèmes qui coopèrent avec
l'homme et qui collait robert pas l'un
de mes collaborateurs m'a dit mais
sébastien est quand même des gens qui
ont posé des normes qui ont réfléchi qui
ont posé le sujet très bien mais dans
notre société nous avons la chance c'est
que nous avons un cambodgien qui parle
clair nous avons des personnes du maroc
de la tunisie de la libye qui parlent
l'arabe
nous avons quelqu'un qui est indien puis
on leur a demandé dans vos langues
coopérer collaborer ça veut dire la même
chose
la réponse a été non donc du coup la
sémantique a vraiment un point très
central est très importante par rapport
à qu'est ce qu'on va faire dire au
système et comment le système va pouvoir
travailler avec nous ce qui signifie
qu'il faut faire attention aux mauvais
repères aux mauvaises interprétations
une mauvaise interprétation d'un système
va au final faire que le produit peut
interpréter et met en difficulté la
personne pour vous redonner une image un
peu plus clair de tout ça je vais aller
sur lyon et le chien alors ça y est il a
parlé de ses grands mères il a parlé de
confiture il a parlé de plein de choses
et là il nous parle d'animaux
qu'est-ce qui nous racontent au final
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle les
algorithmes on peut faire des
similitudes d'un point de vue cognitif
sur les animaux je vous parlais de deux
animaux qui me parlent qu'ils sont le
lion d'un côté le lion est un robot
le robot a pour objectif de réaliser un
programme dans la savane de vivre de
manger de boire de dormir et d'être en
haut de la pyramide
bien sûr ce même lyon va devoir mettre
dans un cirque
dès lors le système va collaborer avec
le dresseur attention le lion est
dangereux le lion il est dans une île
est dans un système où il a qu'une envie
c'est de croquer le dresseur donc il
faut que j'aie équipes ont lieu donc mon
lieu va avoir une cage un système de
protection et le dresseur va être formés
et habilités pour travailler avec le
système est bien sûr à tout moment ce
qu'il faudra pas oublier c'est que le
lion a potentiellement des griffes très
aiguisé peut-être un os entre les
coussinets donc peut-être dangereux et
lui-même ne le sait pas donc selon ce
que l'on appelle la directive machine
est bien le système va voir un bouton
d'arrêt d'urgence qui est le chasseur
avec le chasseur avant le vétérinaire
avec le fusil et l'autre côté vous avez
le chien le chien aveugle
le chien aveugle la différence du lion
est là pour coopérer pour aider l'homme
pour l'aider dans une baisse d'activité
dans une baisse de facultés de capacité
une baisse sur la vision et du coup le
système on va lui apprendre on va lui
donner de l'information et cette
information va lui permettre de
comprendre son environnement et d'aider
l'homme
si vous mettez un lion un aveugle ya de
fortes chances que ça se passe mal je
pense que vous comprenez la terminologie
collaboré à la différence bien sûr d'un
chien dans un cirque ça se passera bien
mais ce sera pas spectaculaire ce sera
pas forcément ce qui est le plus
intéressant
donc tout ça pour dire que
l'interprétation est liée à la culture
est liée à l'environnement dans lequel
le développeur informatique développe
c'est pour ça que je vous ai parlé au
final de ces grands pères de cet
environnement
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'une
mauvaise interprétation tout ça peut
nous emmener
sur des accidents peut nous emmener sur
des incompréhensions effectivement si je
dis aux chiens un arbre va te donner des
caresses et un homme s'est fait pour tes
besoins mais il réalisera le programme
tout bêtement
donc ça veut dire que le développeur
informatique et l'appeler entre
guillemets de cet écosystème et de ceux
de cette façon de deux programmes et nos
systèmes
donc ça veut dire qu'au final une
machine c'est pas froid une machine
c'est fait par des hommes s'est
développée par des hommes c'est maîtrisé
par des hommes dont kylie a quasiment
autant d'algorithmes qui peut l'y avoir
d'hommes de codeurs de conscience
d'environnement dans lequel on va se
situer vous pour terminer sur une image
assez intéressante si on avait été
capable d'avoir des robots allez un
siècle avant galilée
vous imaginez bien le développeur
informatique il va dire à son système
au fait tu as le droit de continuer
jusqu'au bout de la terre et vu qu'elle
est plate
dès que tu vois le vide tu t'arrêtes lui
lance son programme
et qu'est ce qu'il va se passer bah le
robot va continuer de tourner autour de
la tête il va jamais s'arrêter
galileo répondra peut-être gagner un
petit peu si on avait eu effectivement
ce type de système mais ça va dans ce
sens là c'est à dire que le développeur
est limité aussi par rapport à la
culture par rapport à l'environnement
dans lequel il va se trouver au final
tout ce que je viens de vous raconter
c'est surtout ma création entre
guillemets ma constitution la création
de culture via un environnement via un
climat dans lequel je suis et de
comprendre un peu les règles du jeu les
règles du jeu du développeur
informatique de comprendre qu'au final
il faut aussi que le développeur
informatique se connaissent bien mais
connaît son environnement qu'il est du
lien social
si le développeur informatique n'a pas
de sociabilité au final le code sera
froid le système sera dangereux donc
c'est un petit peu tout le combat que je
mène aujourd'hui dans mon activité et la
malchance que j'ai pu avoir c'est que
j'ai pas réussi en fait à retranscrire
ça dans des machines pour aider mes
grands pères malheureusement ils sont
partis trop tôt
mais la petite fierté que j'ai pu avoir
ces quinze jours avant le décès de l'un
des derniers grands pères papyros'n est
décédé à 81 18 ans j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir croiser son regard est dû dire
papilles ça y est c'est parti je me
lance je vais monter ma boîte et je vais
avoir un objectif de créer entre
guillemets cet atelier futuriste
avec des systèmes un compagnon un chien
qui va être notre petite aide si présent
qui va aider l'homme dans son
environnement et je crois que c'était
plus belle fierté entre guillemets que
j'ai pu y avoir c'était de lui croiser
ce message est de dire que l'un de mes
fondateur entre guillemets de ma culture
a pu au moins avoir ce regard pétillant
face à moi et profiter de ses derniers
instants
merci à tous et bonne après midi